danke was ist dein name wird nicht mehr
interessiert kann mein abend meine
lieben freunde wir quatschen heute
wieder dann will sie mit dem wort dafür
habe ich ihnen bereits einige fragen
gestellt ein bisschen eingelagert
bisschen smalltalk dies das hin und her
und er fragt mich jetzt nicht alt bist
du und da antworte ich einfach mal 24
liga clever bot ich bin gespannt wie alt
er ist ich bin wie 60 60
was wie alt bist du jetzt genau also ich
bloß danach irgendwie nicht so richtig
schlau
[Musik]
ich antworte jetzt einfach mal wir
kennen uns doch gar nicht wichtig also
ich meine stimmt ja auch ein wir haben
gerade
das video geht eine minute und wir sind
schon wieder tiefer drin allemal besser
nicht sagen
youtube werbe freundlichkeit ich spiele
spielt jetzt einfach mal mit und fragen
wo haben wir denn geheiratet nein wollen
wir
ich dachte wir haben bereits geheiratet
also das hat er mir so gesagt gerade und
jetzt fragt er mich noch mal wollen wir
warum konntest du mir gerade nicht
antworten
[Musik]
der ist ja geisteskrank eifersüchtig
gerade so voll einen auf hey ich bin die
chantal und wenn mein freund mir nach
einer sekunde nicht an worten hat er
bestimmt in neue ich einfach da einfach
so ok ich glaube wir haben stress haben
wir gerade wie clever bot frage ich ihn
einfach mal ne
na ja anscheinend ja schon also
anscheinend anscheinend ja schon ich
kann mich mal so richtig schreiben
darauf antwortet einfach nur nein ich
beschrieben warum wolltest du dann mit
mir heiraten beziehungsweise wir sind ja
anscheinend verheiratet aber wir sind
doch verheiratet antworte ich als
einfach mal so ein bisschen traurig mit
den drei punkten ein
hey wir sind doch verheiratet hat er
doch geschrieben ihr habt alle gelesen
gehst du morgen auf das konzert von
lukas riehl wtf was ist denn das für ein
themenwechsel plötzlich nein
fragezeichen es ging schade
die fragezeichen
es ging gerade auch unsere hochzeit und
plötzlich geht es um die was ist gehst
du hin frei
lernen da gehst du hin lieber clever bot
ja viel spaß wünsche ich dir dabei wir
haben bei der hochzeit mit ihnen
gesprochen jetzt gruppe
beim konzert wo bei den sonst teufel
also punkt für punkt zurück zur hochzeit
schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal nein ich
heirate dich nicht
ok
aber warum fragst du mich denn dann sag
mir wer bist du wie heißt du eigentlich
vielleicht kann ich dich ja doch
was ich bin luca 4
heiraten schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal
ein spieler spielt komplett mit wann
soll unsere hochzeit stattfinden morgen
so schnell es geht was soll ich anziehen
nichts los sexuell meine lieben freunde
clever wollen natürlich ins herren
roboter hast du eine freundin ein sonst
würde ich ja nicht fragen ob wir
heiraten wollen hätte ich das gar nicht
wie diese unterhaltung hingegangen ist
ich schon okay
packen das hochzeitszimmer jetzt
beiseite und kümmern uns um berufliche
dinge was gibst du eigentlich für einen
beruf aus ich meine wenn uns jetzt lange
darüber lieber unterhalten ein mädchen
fragezeichen
jetzt nicht so ganz was du meinst marx
personals was ist so nach ein paar
sekunden später nach sonne ist die
freude von sonic ja klar nicht die ich
schreibe einfach mal ja vielleicht komme
ich ja dadurch im gespräch mit ihm was
ist dein lieblingssong von ihr
die sängerin atemlos helene fischer ja
das ist meine lieblings in denen fische
atemlos hab ich wirklich morgens mittags
abends beim sportler der dusche ich
singe von warner einen song der heißt
mach mal du sollst wie ich checke mich
mehr was er von mir will ehrlich gesagt
sag was nettes hat er mir jetzt
geschrieben von einer antwort ich
einfach mal du bist hübsch danke du auch
xd
hey was ist das hier was ist dass er
lacht einfach nur noch ich einfach
wissen was dein beruf ist was ist dein
beruf reichen jetzt einfach habe keinen
also arbeitslos oder oder wie jetzt
genau das ist er braucht teilweise so
lange zu beantworten ja bin schüler ach
so ich bin youtuber schreibe ich jetzt
einfach mal kanal luca name
wir hatten roboter
gemacht und uns danke was ist dein name
würde mich interessieren
oh mein gott
das ist der name von clever clever bord
heißt kevin ich frag einfach kevin
fragezeichen ist mein freund und sitzt
gerade neben mir
also ihr heißt helfen und kevin oder wie
soll ich das jetzt verstehen weil der
kleine aber da ist der name fort was ist
dein nachname kevin georg das würde mich
auch mal interessieren den möchte ich
sie nicht sagen ist okay dann gutes
recht privatsphäre und so sehr wichtig
was meinst du dass das mir nicht sagen
muss brauchst spielen ein komma du also
lieber clever was spielst du mit puppen
ja ich liebe minecraft minecraft sind ja
keine gruppen also ich weiß nicht was
irgendwie durcheinander gebracht hatte
der kevin georg oder etwas anderes
trennen
[Applaus]
komm mir gerade in eine leicht sexuelle
richtung was willst du denn treiben mein
lieber clever wort frage ich einfach mal
ich trage dich was du tun willst
ja
jo stimmungstöter des jahres was wollen
wir treiben
da habe ich ihn jetzt einfach mal um
wir wollen uns treiben
santos tennis
ich glaube das heißt wie alt bist du 24
yo también
et al
wieso sprechen ich spreche da
da habe ich einfach mal in berlin
komm bitte zu mir
kevin georg warum bist du denn jetzt so
sexuell unterwegs hier bin georg komma
ich bin nicht schwul also das ist ja
lieb dass du mir das hier schreibst bist
du weiblich nein ich bin männlich und
ich bin heterosexuell also völlig in
ordnung wenn du hier auf mich schwer ist
aber ich auch nicht
ja ich weiß du hast auch kevin georg und
bist ja auch ein mann oder ist sehr
clever bot man wird ja auch einen mann
oder frage ich jetzt einfach mal nein
ich bin ein mädchen bist du weiblich
nein ich auch nicht du bist ja auch ein
mann nein ich bin ein mädchen pro was
ist denn jetzt sache
bist du junge oder mädchen die frage
stelle ich jetzt einmal und er sagt er
ist ein mädchen wieso nicht okay und du
heißt fragezeichen
das ist nämlich jetzt die sache valentin
und schreibt jetzt nicht valentin ist
aber ein jungenname klar
kevin georg valentin
oder wie jetzt nein lukas lukas bücher
was ist lukas bücher wann hast du
geburtstag 21 2 1996 habe ich geburtstag
man lieber clever bot bzw kevin georg
valentin wenn du 19 690 geworden wo das
kannst du aber nicht 14
bin ich bin hatte ich bin nicht 14
schreibe ich einfach mal wie alt bist du
dann 24 hab ich hab vorhin schon gesagt
also ich weiß nicht warum das jetzt
gerade die ganze zeit ein thema ist und
jetzt auch vor allem schon zum dritten
mal
a
und du wie alt bist du
noch lockt ja sag doch einfach dein
alter es ist nach
clever bot los gehts ja
machtlos
sagt euch will er wissen mit wem ich
schreibe das war toll
das video hat
gar keinen roten faden lass uns über die
klimaerwärmung sprechen schreiben jetzt
einfach mal ich hasse die schule ok
thema ende noch eine frage fragezeichen
ja also ich hab mir vor dem video
gedacht mich würde mal interessieren was
du halt beruflich machst dann
herausgefunden schüler dein name ist
kevin georg valentin du bist aber ein
mädchen von daher würde ich mich jetzt
einfach fragen wo wohnst du denn lieber
clever bot kann ich nicht sagen
privatsphäre oder wir sind ehrlich wir
haben verschieben schade
banane schade banane baidu com
[Musik]
einfach mal
in der unterhaltung entsagen
ich muss los wurde an der stelle ich das
heute wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wird euch
mal wieder clever worden mit luca mit
mir also
mit wem eigentlich auch sonst wenn euch
das video hier auf jeden fall gefallen
da würde ich mich sehr darüber einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video ihr
freund schreibt ihr mal irgendwas in die
kommentare
es ist einfach von youtube algorithmus
häufig ist es so dass sollte meinen
kanal abonnieren aber die videos dann
nicht angezeigt bekommen also
kommentiert einfach irgendwas oder
schickt dieses video her und eure
freunde meines lustig fanden ja und
jetzt verstehen wir uns auch schon im
outro wenn ihr noch kein abonnent von
einem kanal sei dann klickt einfach hier
oben auf den smiley draußen ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
wenn ihr bock auf merchandise von mir
haben dann klickt dort oben auch drauf
also nicht aus dem freilich sondern oft
müssen wird das bild daneben und jetzt
die letzte folge luca quatsch
wincklerbad verlinkt da war es auch
ziemlich lustig weil er alles über mich
schon gar nichts